all right one last story about get this
a reporter turned rescuer weatherman
paul burt of australia seven news was on
a beach reporting on dangerous currents
we've all done that right when a
ten-year-old though did you notice
dangerous courage nate's
we got to get nate out into a hurricane
this guy's some waiters i'm not scared i
took on linebackers
yeah i say nothing nothing so he's
reporting doing a live shot and then
behind him a ten-year-old boy is swept
away with the water behind him so guess
what bert does he jumps into action and
he comes back on cam looking like this
the ten-year-old boy got dragged out
exactly what i was saying
and uh pictures behind us you can see us
all ambose out there but it was dragged
out for the gutter we raced out there
unfortunately i had to get my shirt off
which is not a good look but we got out
there and we we looked for him and then
one of the other fellas found him we got
out there and basically grabbed him and
and pulled him back to shore he's very
lucky
yeah that was him running into the
search right and there he is on air
explaining just how he casually helped
save a child that wasn't
related to him he just jumped in just
saw what was happening and took action
wow uh david hasselhoff would approve
the hof would approve but just the idea
of jumping into the water in the middle
of a live shot and then coming back no
big thing that's awesome all right